hello YouTube just lovers in my friends
this is bingen here and I like to
welcome you for the second game of most
attacking chests now the game which I
will show you today will teach us two
important lessons the first lesson which
especially I have learnt from this game
is whenever you are facing a big name or
person which is much higher rated than
you then the best way to come out is to
play aggressive or the attacking chests
and the second lesson we can learn from
this game is whenever you are attacking
them even they are likely to make
mistakes and we have every chance of
winning the game so join with me and
learn and enjoy one of the very good
attacking game
now before we start let me give you a
brief history this game was played way
back in the year 2000 in the city of
Budapest between wgm Hongkong Truong and
an I am ever gone
now the opening was the bouillabaisse
gambit so wide start with the d4 and
black responded with the Knight f6
enough to see four black plays ePHI so
this is one of the very sound and
attacking or playing against the 4c full
system and I personally recommend you
that if you want to learn attacking
chess against d4 then you should try
with up his gambit nevertheless here how
goes for the main line so she captured
the pawn and black plays Knight to g4
and here wrong place the knight to f3
variation now I personally do not like
Knight to f3 variation because of this
move which is Bishop to c5 and now you
can see two pcs are attacking the f2
square and that's why white has to
passively play III and here black will
continue with the Knight to c6 so now
black is going to regain the pawn and
here home goes for the main line so she
played Bishop to e2 can't recapture the
pole and after Knight to c3 can't castle
on the Kings side and Hong did the same
and here Khan played one of the very
aggressive system by the black start
with this move so first of all he
capture this night and after white
recapture with the Bishop black played
Knight to e5 so now you can see the
black is eyeing for the bishop pair so
Hong has to retrieve the Bishop to e2
and now black played rook to e8 and here
Y responded with very nation looking a3
now idea is very simple white wants to
expand on the Queen side with the move
before
and here comes the very attacking idea
by black starting with the move e5 now
fi is a very dual-purpose move now the
first thing you can see here is not only
it's stopping the b4 but black has a
very amazing idea starting with Luke - a
six and then Luke swings across - it's
six where your black green can come out
to h4 and they all are set to attack on
h2 so this is one of the very attacking
theory of the Budapest let's see how
Hong responded to this so here she
responded with the MU B 3 so idea is to
put the bishop on b2 and black played as
usual rook to a six so now Luke wants to
swing across through at six and here all
responded with one of the attacking
system by wired starting with this move
which is Knight to d5
now nine to d4 has two merits first it
is looking at the critical square c7 and
not only that in future if white wants
to expand with the b4 then the knight
can protect the pawn so overall it's a
very good attacking move by the white
and here cannot responded with one of
the most direct attacking move start
with Queen to h4 so you can see now the
very simple plan of the black is to
swing this rook across to at six and
made the white on the issue
and this attacks looks so potent that
white completely forget that the c7
point is hanging by the way I think Kahn
was more prepared for this variation and
very wisely Hong avoided that variation
because this IMS are very much prepared
if they play this kind of attacking line
so very wisely Hong first of all played
g3 Queen goes to s3 and now she played
efore so now you can see this bishop is
covering the critical ends at six square
but now Khan responded with rook to d6
so now you can see this rook is spinning
the knight to the Queen and here white
played b4 so now you can see this phone
is attacking the bishop and not only
that if the bishop goes back then white
can play
sefa and that will not only attack the
roof but that will also shut down this
Bishop on this diagonal so here black
has to play very energetically and very
aggressively otherwise white will have a
very good and easy game now before we
move on what I will do in this video is
every single time when it's black to
move I want you to pause the video and
think what you will play if you are
black in this position and then you will
compare the move which has been played
in the game by the Kahn and at the end
you will count how many perfect matches
you did with the car and first on that
you can score yourself okay so now it's
black to move pause the video and think
what you will play as a black okay here
can't play this very good move which is
root 2 e 6 and now you can see this two
roots are joined together and now they
are targeting the at six square so for
example here if white greedily capture
this Bishop so B cross C Phi then black
has this move which is look too at six
so now you can see black is threatening
a checkmate so first of all white has to
capture one of the rook so after Bishop
takes and rook takes still the mate is
there and the only logical way to defend
this maid is to play this move which is
first of all Bishop to h5 and after rook
captures White has to give this check
and after King to a fade White has to
surrender the Queen to stop the mid so
queen cross rook and after Queen
recapture white can capture the bishop
so you can see right now White has to
route versus the Queen but the thing is
Fight Night cannot come out and that is
the main drawback of this position and a
simple line can goes like this
so black can play this very attacking
move which is g5 and after very natural
looking F for black can play Knight f3
check and after King to g2 black can
actually capture this pawn because after
row
h1 black and play Queen to e2 chair and
after King to h3 black and play this
very good move which is h5 and Fritz
just state route captures s2 but
afterwards g4 and King to h4 not only
white will gain or exchange but you can
see this rook is very remote and this
night will not come out soon so that's
why you can see at this position B cross
C fuh is not playable so here white
plays a very good move which is Bishop
to h5 so you can see now this diagonal
has been blocked and now pause for a
moment and find out what you will play
as a black
now if you can find this move then you
must be a very good attacking player and
the move is Bishop to d4 and first sight
it looks impossible because it's okay
that this bishop is attacking the rook
but yes bishop is right now hanging with
the Queen and we have to see what
happens if why take the bishop so queen
cross d4 well afterwards there is a very
good line goes like this so black will
play queen cross h5 and after Queen to
d1 try to exchanging the Queen Black has
a very good move which is Knight to f3
plus and after King to g2 this move
which is rook to f6 and now you can see
not only this rook is protecting the
Nile but black is threatening to capture
the h2 which checkmate so even after
Knight takes f6 and rook takes f6 threat
remain the same and here there are three
replies for the white and let's deal
with them each by tongue so first of all
if the white play here h3 then black can
responded with the d6 so now you can see
this bishop is eyeing for the s6 edge 3
square and if the rook to h1 then Bishop
cross h3 anyways because if white take
the bishop then black has this move
which is nice to h4 plus so it's not
only giving a check to the King but you
can see now this Queen is hanging so
after rook takes Knight black and simply
capture the Queen
so that is s3 line if here right place
h4 then black can play this move which
is Queen to g4 and after Bishop to b2
attacking the roof pasta fall Knight
captures h4 with check and after King to
g2 black has a very good reply which is
rook to a3 so you can see not only it's
avoiding the exchange of the Queen but
also stopping why to capturing the night
and there is a very simple idea by the
black is to play d6 and then just go for
the mate and the base reply here for the
white will be Queen to d4 so threatening
the g7 mate but here black has a winning
move which is
look to be three
and there are so much tears over here
first of all you can see any moment this
group can capture the bishop the second
but the most potent threat is this night
can jumps to the f3 and it will folk the
king and a queen and you see the squares
this all red squares Queen does not have
any excess that means when the Queen
moves black and capture this bishop
so that is h4 and the best move here
suggested by fritz which is this one
rook to h1 but after this black and
played b6 and after the normal move like
h4 black can play Bishop to g4 and no
wonder Paul doesn't want to go into this
position you can see all four pieces of
the black are near the white king and
look at the all white pieces they all
are sitting at their original square no
GM will go for this position so very
wisely here all responded with rook to a
- it's black to move please pause for a
moment and try what the Khan has played
and to be your surprise Khan has played
this move which is rook to g6 and I must
admit when first time I see this game I
didn't even understand what exactly
going on it's that much hard to pick
this game now after rook to g6 again why
it has a few options so you can see
white can capture this bishop so the
bishop is hanging and also white can
capture this rook now let's deal each by
tone so first of all what happens if
bishop cross g6 well if Bishop cross g6
then the very simple answer will be
Knight to g5 it will be a very hard for
the white to stop the mate unless until
white has to give up the Queen so a
sample line can goes like this so Queen
captures night
and after queen recapture white can go
for this line which is first full night
check poking the King and a bishop and
after King to afaid first of all white
can save the bishop so Bishop to a5
attacking the Queen and after Queen goes
to f3 white can capture the bishop and
after rook to c6 Bishop cross d7 to
cross c4 Bishop to b5 and rope to c6
White has it three pcs for a queen but
the bad part about the white is this
night does not have any running square
so that means this night is temporary
trap and look at the black pieces they
are very very aggressively pace I will
much prefer black over here so that is
Bishop cross g6 now what happens if
Queen cross d4
now if here Queen cross v4 then black
can respond first of all capture of the
bishop and after Knight to e7 black can
play King to f8 and after Knight cross
g6 come with the chair black can simply
capture the H phone and at first sight
it looks like black is losing this
position but no it's not because now
whenever the Queen grunts for example in
our case let's say if the Queen goes to
the c5 then black and T is wide with one
more move which is b6 and after Queen
kept to c7 black has a simple drawing
position so it start with the move
Knight to f3 and after King to g2 black
can play this move which is night to h4
and now you can see if the King goes to
x3 or the G 1 then the moves will be
repeated so the only logical square
looks like G captures h4 but afterwards
black has a perpetual checks so we into
g4 check King to h1 Queen to f3 check
King to g1 and King to g4
will leads to the draw and of course i
was not satisfied with that and finally
i think white here miss the winning move
which is Knight to f4
and now you can see it's attacking the
Queen and the rook I think probably she
thought that after rook cross g6 black
has a very attacking position but here
she completely overlooked this move
which is king - h1 and now you can see
queen is attack the rookie's attack and
a simple line can runs like this so
black can play this move which is Bishop
cross F - so it has a discovery to the
Queen but after simple Knight cross
Queen rook cross Queen Bishop cross rook
black rook is hanging so black has to
forcefully go for this move which is
route cross s3 but after Luke cross f2
what emerge with a piece up so see when
you are attacking even big players
cannot see good moves this is a very
very good example that when you are
attacking so much fearlessly a big
players can do mistakes and here hong
panics and she played King to h1 and I
think this is a big big mistake because
now black has a chance to get rid of one
of the potential attacker of the white
with this move which is
ruk cross be file and again you can see
here why it has a choice which group to
capture if Bishop captures g6 then
Knight to g4 so the value of this
response of the white will be C cross
defy but afterwards it's black turn and
again pause the video and find out which
movie you will play
I hope you find out this move which is
d6 and again you can see there are two
pieces are hanging but this time it's
impossible for white to capture either
of the pieces so for example if Queen
cross d4 then you can see this rook is
support less now
so simply black can capture the rook and
this will lead to checkmate
so that is impossible and if Bishop
captures g6 then you should play Knight
to f3 again so decoy so please remember
Queen cannot capture the night because
rook is hanging and if Queen cannot
capture then it cannot avoid the mate at
h2 so both the pieces cannot be captured
after d6
so that leads to the only reply played
in the game by the hall which here she
played Bishop to f4 but here again pause
the video and find out a good move by
the black
okay I hope you find this movie which is
look to f6 and now idea is very simple
Black has come out from all attack of
the white and now black is simply
threatening to play Bishop to g4
and here honk responded with Bishop to
e2 so now if the Bishop to g4 then f3
maybe on the card again it's black to
move pause for a moment and find out the
good move
and the move is GFI now please note that
bishop cross e phi is impossible because
of simple look to at six and the mid has
been threatened and if now g4 then black
can simply capture the bishop and white
king will be a goner so bishop cross
Aoife is not possible so that leads to
the only reply that bishop has to
forcefully capture this which should
cross d5 to save the critical square at
six but here comes the best move of the
game take as much as your time and find
out the best move of the black
and the best move of the game is rook to
f3 now why this is a base move the first
thing is it cuts the communication of
this diagonally so that's why now Knight
to g4 is on agenda which leads to the
chat made at s2 and the good thing is
white cannot even touch the rook so for
example if Bishop cross f3 then again we
have Knight cross f3 and White Queen
cannot capture the night that rook is
untouchable so that means that leads to
the only reply laughs which has played
by the hall which is g4 now idea is very
simple white wants to play Bishop to f4
and save the mate so for example when
black plays Knight to g4 then white can
play Bishop to f4 and try to see the
middle now here the last move played by
the Khan
pause the video and find out the
finishing blow and I hope you find this
move which is look cross f2 and how just
given up over here see the amazing
beauty about this game now first thing
you can note our here there are two
checkmates exist so not only on h2 but
there is also checkmate exist on gg2 and
if white rope capture this rope then we
have a knight to f2 comes with a [ __ ]
king and a queen so very amazing and
attacking game by Khan I hope you enjoy
and learn my second attacking chess game
please feel free to comment on this
video and I'll meet you soon bye